اشتباكاتهم متقاطعه بالخرطوم وتفاؤل
بمحادثات جده بعد ثلاث سنوات على الجريمه
الاعدام لقاتل الهاشمي في العراق ثلاث
عبوات في المشروب الطاقات تودي بحياه طفله
عراقيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم الى
[موسيقى]
البدايه من اخر التطورات في السودان
فبينما يجتمع ممثلو طرفي النزاع في جده
بعد المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه اندلعت
اشتباكات متقطعه في العاصمه الخرطوم سيما
في محيط القصر الجمهوري والشارع المطار
وسط تحليق لطيران الجيش ورد لقوات دعم
السريع بالمضادات الارضيه الجيش السوداني
قال ان قوته صدت هجوما شنتته الدعم السريع
على قياده قوات الدفاع الجوي ودمرت عدد من
العربات واستولت على الثلاث عربات قتاليه
فضلا عن قتل عدد من العناصر المهاجمه وفقا
لبيان الجيش
بعد نحو ثلاث سنوات على مقتله اصدرت محكمه
الجنايات الرصافه في العراق حكما بالاعدام
شنقا حتى الموت بحق المدان احمد حمداوي
عويد عن جريمه قتل الناشط سياسي هشام
الهاشمي مع امكانيه الاستئناف الحكم
الهاشمي كان اختلال في يونيو 2020 وخضعت
محاكمه للتاجيل لما يقارب ست مرات رغم
اعتراف المتهم بقتل الهاشمي بعد تحقيق
بشريمته التي تم اعتبارها عملا ارهابيا ان
القاتل كان ضابط شرطه برتبه ملازم اول
وضع النووي خطير حذر منه رفاييل جراسيل
مدير العام للوكاله الدوليه التقت الدوريه
بخصوص محطه طاقه نوويه في سوبالوجيا والتي
تسيطر عليها روسيا في اوكرانيا كروسي قال
ان الوضع العام في المنطقه القريبه
منفاروجيا النوويه اصبح غير قابل للتنبؤ
بشكل متزايد ويحتمل ان يكون خطيرا معبرا
عن قلقه على الامن والسلامه النوويين في
المحطه او بضروره حمايه المنشاه النوويه
الكبيره مطالبا بالضغط على جميع الاطراف
للتزام بهذا الهدف الحيوي
حادث ماساوي شهده العراق بعد ان توفي طفله
عراقيه تبلغ من العمر 13 عاما اثر شربها
ثلاث عبوات من مشروبات الطاقه خلال اقل من
24 ساعه وفقا لمصر مقرب من اسرتها مصر
واضاف ان طفله وبعد تناولها ثالث علبه
انهارت وتم اسعافها الى مركز صحي في
محافظه كركوك لكنها فارقت الحياه هناك
الاطباء قاموا بتشريح الجثه وارسال عينات
الفحص لتحديد سبب الوفاه مرشحين ان نسبه
كبيره من الكافيين والسعرات الحراريه
الكثيره دخلت جسمها جراء مشروب الطاقه
من عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي حيث شارك خبيرنا
امريكي الى ان تقنيه الحديثه من الذكاء
الاصطناعي
ستؤدي الى فقدان 80% من الوظائف في
المستقبل القريب ولكنه راى في ذلك جانبا
ايجابيا معتبرا ان الناس سيجدون اشياء
افضل يقومون بها الباحث اصار ضجه خلال قمه
ويب وبعرضها الممرضه الاليه جويس والمصممه
الاعتناء بكبار السن في دور رعايتهم اشار
الى انه يمكنها ان يكون تعلم ايضا مجالا
مهما لروبوتات وكذلك الاعمال المنزليه
اضافه لوظائف اداريه